now now on that issue specifically of of
of virtue so in our society um the
people who usually want to talk about it
the most tend to be um the conservative
end of the spectrum or traditional end
because they're like you know we need to
have virtue back in our life and virtue
is kind of an old fashiony sounding term
so you get people like um William it's
back in I want to say the the 90s
writing a book of Virtues and it's
supposed to be you know a bunch of
stories that show like you know here's
what it's like to be Thrifty or generous
or stuff like that but this stuff winds
up being crap because it doesn't provide
you with like you said a
structure um if you're going to call
something a virtue and this is the
problem back in Aristotle's time and
this is part of what
um uh Plato is struggling with a lot in
in his um dialogues right or having
Socrates and his interlocutors struggle
with you got to have something more in
mind than just it's a warm fuzzy term
that we like to hear you've got to be
able to say what actually makes a person
virtuous as opposed to merely seeming
virtuous or doing a virtuous action but
not really being virtuous and they start
they start kids off with this quite
young um and it's it's not just cultural
conservatives who who do this now
there's also um others as well um you
know like uh in in a let's call it a
more generalized sort of let's be nice
to each other kind of thing like in in K
through 12 classrooms mostly like on the
K through uh five side well they'll be
like okay we've got our virtues board
which kid demonstrated this virtue this
week you know what who who's who's uh
going to try to work on this virtue but
they don't tell them what the hell it
actually means right and in part because
a lot of these teachers aren't qualified
to um actually say anything about it
because they never bothered to study and
it wouldn't take them long but they
never bothered to study any sort of
systematic approach to the virtues
whether it's Aristotelian or stoic or
platonic or you know what have you even
even reading Benjamin Franklin I mean he
talks about the the virtues right in his
autobiography and he tells you what what
they
are um and so this is this is a really
big problem because when you um
introduce all this virtue vocabulary and
the concept of virtue but you don't give
anybody any structure all you're really
giving them are are tropes that they can
use rhetorically to like make themselves
feel good or look good or criticize
other people but you're not giving them
uh a developmental path you're not
saying okay you want to be temperate um
here's how you here's how you become
tempered here's what tempered people
look like here's the motivations that
you need to have you know um so I I
think this is this is quite important
I'm actually thinking by the way down
the line of doing a class that would be
specifically about virtue ethics and it
would be a much longer class so it would
start with like some Plato and Aristotle
and the stoic and Cicero and all that
and then it would look at like how do
they how do they parse these out what do
they mean by
virtue and then look at some of the
later work in medieval and and modern uh
thinkers and then look at the supposed
20 20th century Revival of virtue ethics
which is kind of a parochial thing right
um it only I mean it's only a Revival in
uh analytic philosophy because they'd
forgotten about virtue but plenty of
other people were still talking about it
during the 20th century and you get some
really cool
um contributions that are made by you
know um Alice Ambrose and Alistair
McIntyre and you know up to the present
like people like Robert Audi um you know
who's got a great piece on um on virtue
ethics in business where he like says
here's what a virtue looks like here's
how it applies I'm generalizing here
this is what it would you know apply to
in in business um and so I'm thinking
about you know um putting together like
a much longer class on that because I
think it's an important um topic you
know figuring out how how does virtue
ethics actually work you do see people
out there embracing virtue ethics but
it's this very like topown super general
you know um it's a it's virtue ethics is
different than utilitarianism or
deontology and it's so abstract that you
don't see how it would actually fit into
people's lives or any sort of robust
tradition and it keeps on making the
same mistakes like saying well if a
virtue is a middle State can you have a
middle state of a middle State and
obviously if you read Aristotle he says
no it doesn't work that way the middle
state is the middle State you can't have
like too much moderation you know
something like that oh yeah Harold has
uh the uh the thing yeah that's that's
it um I actually use that in my business
ethics classes and I'm thinking about
incorporating it believe it or not
into my regular ethics classes because
his
presentation of what a virtue should
include is so good another one I'm
actually thinking about
incorporating is aliser
McIntyre's uh essay from I think
1991 called how to seem virtuous without
being so and IT addresses the issue of
like you know well how do we understand
virtues in today's society you know and
I think think about it so somebody could
grab the nickam McCain ethics and they
like read it through in a kind of kind
of um sloppy way and they're like oh man
yeah I like courage um and they don't
really pay attention to the things that
he says about courage and they're like
courage is just me you know stuffing
down my fear and running into the
burning building
um and then they encourage people to act
like that you know they show them some
TV clips of I know firefighters or
people like that and they're like this
is what cages you need to be like this
kids you know that would actually be um
damaging more than than helpful I think
you
know